bring on the fried chicken baby
welcome to the tasty cook-off today
we're cooking Fried Chicken competing
against me are to fellow tasty producers
I'm Mike I'm making a Szechuan style
fried trigger hi I'm Lee a I'm making
tebah sake fried chicken today hi my
name is Robin and I'm gonna be making
buttermilk marinated fried chicken
the seasoned the buttermilk with some
salt pepper and cayenne pepper to give
it a nice kick I'm using boneless
skinless chicken thighs very flavorful
juicy and tender so I'm gonna cover this
buttermilk marinated chicken and put it
in the fridge for an hour I'm gonna
serve two sauces honey with lemon juice
and chili pepper and the other one is
going to be Greek yogurt and dill dip
garlic powder salt and pepper fresh dill
and some lemon juice and I'll let this
sit in the fridge for about an hour
saw the flavors merge for my batter I'm
using flour salt pepper cayenne pepper
garlic powder I was gonna mix all that
so I'm taking my chicken out of the
marinade and I'm gonna dredge it in the
flour we are ready for some oil action
right I want to fry these at 350 degrees
for about seven minutes or until it gets
a nice golden brown that's someone's
golden goodness this is something I
would do if I have a lot of friends over
and we have a light of fried chicken and
playing games I think if you're thinking
about traditional fried chicken this is
a really good version of that you really
don't need to do a lot to get great
flavors from your food I like to keep
things as simple as possible because if
it's complicated I get confused and
everything turns into a disaster so
today I'm gonna make a swan style fried
chicken two parts cornstarch 1 part
flour little seasoning and water I'm
gonna whisk it all together we're gonna
make the spice mix we start with the
most important ingredient roundup
Sichuan peppercorns it brings a
spiciness but it's not the same heat as
like a traditional chili and it makes
your mouth tangle a little bit cumin
chili flakes by the teaspoon of salt and
most importantly besides Sichuan field
sugar sweeten it up a little bit it's
time to batter up the chicken and then
we're gonna fry it we're frying this
chicken twice this one is the low fry
and we're actually gonna fry it again at
high temperature after it rest for a
little bit
meanwhile I'm gonna prep the aromatics
for stir frying this at the end
garlic and the ginger and some dried
chilies we're gonna toss those let them
sweat a little bit and then we're gonna
add our chicken drumsticks and then we
want to put in the rest of our spice mix
and you can put in a little bit more a
little bit less depending on how much
heat you like in this stuff my first job
ever in the restaurant industry I worked
in a Chinese restaurant the beginning of
my education and food basically was just
working with a bunch of these Chinese
cooks I learned a ton back then and I've
carried it with me my whole life I'm
making sabaki fried chicken today I'm
going to call chicken wings with potato
starch potato starch gives nice crispy
shells compared with flour for this
recipe I'm going to fry it twice first
I'm going to fry chicken for seven to
eight minutes I can make sure the
chicken is cooked through and then I'm
going to raise the temperature and give
the nice golden brown color to the wings
all of our chickens very different but I
think mine it's great because it has
like maybe thick sauce and you wanna
lick your fingers I'm using soy sauce
mirin sake sugar it's very simple and
I'm grating garlic and give more flavor
to it simmer until kinda becoming syrupy
texture now I'm coating going to its
sauce completely and you don't need to
cook inside of the pan too long because
it's it will get soggy very nice and
shiny just for final touch I sprinkle
with toasted sesame seeds that's it
good it's not only paste but also like
atmosphere so like when there were ue
outside or like when you're eating with
it makes food taste better I've been
told the losers have to do the dishes
all of us are eating each other's fried
chicken so I think we all learn at the
end also view bites chicken is really
good it's very different so it's kind of
difficult to compare I think it's like
three of us making totally different
thing
[Music]
you taste that spice and the breading
which is good the Greek yogurt dip is
like super light so it kind of balances
it out it just hits your palate and
you're just like I like kind of wakes
you up I think I like the honey having
like the sweetness balance it out the
super good reaso juicy
it's like sweet oh my god spicy at the
same time like you just get a little bit
of a tingle but your mouth isn't like on
fire because I've never had something
that tastes like this yeah Mina
that sauce what is in that song you need
to bow that up and sell it girl it's
like sweet and salty sticky and the meat
is falling off of the bone and ends in
our mouth
Robbins was what fried chicken should be
true in my opinion crunchy simple batter
but you had that kick from the Cayenne
the spices on Mike's are really good too
and like a totally new flavor I mean
they were all so good
but I think that resaw the sausage is
good I thought next level
so do we want like a classic or
something new
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]